and then we had Star Wars a whole bunch
Star Wars and they had galaxy heroes and
the old republic at bala front on behind
them hey we just like me we're making
Star Wars games like you know we've
already made a bunch is some more
unnamed games that will probably come
out and then yes a couple years yeah so
they didn't name any of these but did
show baby glimpses yeah little teasers
of three yeah one two three yeah so I
guess I win by default you do and new
battlefront 2017 coming from motive
coming out in 2017 sorry yep on the show
at new action adventure game calling out
a visceral then they had respawns third
person game which I said was in a
different era yeah yeah which acoustic
kind of mean anything I mean there's so
big yeah big time line to work with so
yeah and the whole thing kind of felt
like one of those like paper
announcements where they use this to
like get a lot of talented people to
come and help me aims at the dev that we
you call that last you see there was
like an x-wing or a TIE fighter in
virtual reality no no that was I was I
you say what you said either way we
would definitely talk about it and yeah
there was a little glimpse of it just
there they certainly look like someone
in a headset so that guy that next wing
this guy used to work on far cry 4 right
so it'd be interested to see if he went
straight from that to motive or respawn
member level respawns looks interesting
because it's there they're all about the
lightsaber fights and I'm instantly
thinking oh man I'd love to play some
more Jedi Knight multiplayer like I
watching the lightsaber fights right now
is just really intense so he's loving it
yea big AMISOM take massive fan of the
sabers and then yeah they went into
capital games a little bit with what
what they're up to open sometimes I am
but yeah we saw a little sneak peek of
three seconds baby having babies hey
looks all right julia is up for and it's
pretty well Morgan is like 11 yeah good
boy Manny standpoint um yeah we get it
for that let's get some face time for
both Amy and Jade but yeah like yeah
we're heading huge Star Wars project in
the charge on both of those and they
also sort of said that there was a bunch
more content coming to the Old Republic
aunty
font and stuff like that so yeah I mean
yeah he's making a lot of Star Wars if
your case right yes they are hopefully
we see some more gameplay of some of
them I just felt a little bit like oh
you mean not yeah you got the blue walls
you gave me enough that I can't complain
but like not enough to say she look next
different segments look at least a
little bit of something yeah come on
time to get use models yeah yeah no
talking just crossed with a visceral but
no yeah we'll see yeah its battle force
will be multiplayer-focused if there's
no like the visceral game kind of handle
the single player status side of things
rice yeah I wonder they tip the Hat like
titanfall half as well guess we'll have
to wait and see we have to wait to see
this little bit of this three seconds
yes hot game reactions are very
important yeah yeah so everyone just sit
quietly I got bad wait hey all right so
second man okay we got ok here we go
yeah high dynamic range I mean boom it's
real pretty there you go Freddy three
suggested banners waving in the wind
yeah little details see ya and then that
was it for Star Wars for a little while